in der korona krise handeln wir uns nur
von woche zu woche oder von monat zu
monat eine zweite welle wie wir sie im
frühjahr hatten mit solchen folgen nicht
leisten zweiter lockdown können wir uns
nicht leisten hat die kanzlerin gesagt
aber jetzt gibt es genau diesen zweiten
lok da die verordnen die vier wochen
therapie wenn man es sagen kann vier
wochen therapie aber was ist wenn diese
therapie in diesen vier wochen nicht
anschlägt eine solche pandemie sun
naturkatastrophe sie verändert ihr
gesicht ständig und deshalb ist es sehr
sehr schwer
längerfristige vorhersagen was ist denn
hier los haben wir kein parlament mehr
oder was ist doch klar das sorgt auch
für wut unsere regierung darf einfach
nicht länger sich durch diese krise
durchhangeln jeder deutsche hat einen
corona plan verdient der länger hält als
bloss vier wochen